okay this is Joe it's quite peaceful you
can be joking so now the reason why
Tyler was review this is why I see Tim
look at the context Ollie's divorce yes
the man has the power actually you know
what I was doing a little research about
this matter yeah and I found something
really profound it's gonna come find it
is this we look at context why was that
really why does the man have the power
button on the woman even though as
Jewish people Jewish people the woman
has absolutely no right of devotion is
called the gate
and it's hard to get yeah it's got it
yep basically the man has to give it if
the man doesn't give it there is
traditional until today there's
documentaries on it that she's doing
they're married to any Stanton woman has
a right to our support divorce for ah
yeah so you would say to the man
I won't need to divorce me I do not want
to be given at least yeah I want to I
want to go if not she can go to a amount
a scholar and through that person to get
divorced however why does the man have
the right to divorce but a woman recent
study showed in every certified is
recent and the Susan is wrong yet
that woman was 70 percent more likely to
initiate a break break and I love what's
the woman can testify to the fear and I
know it's personal incidences yeah okay
I know friends as well yeah when a woman
gets upset my documentaries that's why
that's most of the times a woman gets
emotional and give me the most
give me the ghost while my I'm not
joking yet there is a lot of work a
testament is when a woman gets emotional
the most we close me I'm gonna be moving
she doesn't mean it but she says it if
the woman had the power of divorce oh my
gosh oh my goodness the OBD was everyday
having a presenter it was really was me
and you came home late
tolik there was me the reason why the
wound the manners what the power is
because there is a difference that's
what we say the way your biology and my
biology is different you have you to
multitask
very hard I color the woman convener
flips the iCard in myself yeah but
that's not taking into consideration
that there are women that when they said
it was there between Annika betrayer
that's why they have the right in Islam
that if they wanted it was in demand is
not given them the divorce because it's
Allah belongs to the man yeah it's not
easy process it's a lot easy for a man
to doesn't want to divorce her then
that's it no no no no this is what a
Jewish the Jews yes you're finished if
the man isn't it wasn't you in prison
or stomach Li you can also pull up you
can easily ask another man sorry another
man no you can ask your husband what
they both I want you to divorce me is
not you can go to a sauna
that's what number one why was this
revealed let me tell you I was you and
this was profound I'm not good to be is
a he says the reason why this was
revealed was the following hey can I
ruin it those days you know what they
would do it woman they would say I
divorce you she wants to move on with
her life
no I take you back and then you get it
was already enough she was no I take you
back she was imprisoned that's why I'm
on legislated it's a three and and
there's another wisdom behind the system
after the fleet arrives if you give to
lock her out once yes you have argument
we make ups but you must go by you give
another teller you make off of you the
third one on the third one when we give
it turn up game over you cannot marry
that woman again she has to move on with
her life get married have a knife if
that marriage doesn't work out then you
can renew your contract now let me tell
you why system because in a man's mind
he's thinking if I give to rock there's
a chance I could lose her forever so
that's the reason why a man cannot abuse
it because if he doesn't abuse it his
wife that once once he gives the first
alarm was finished you cannot get with
them impossible that's why you have to
when you give her up you have to think
to yourself okay I'm giving this based
on that I'm never gonna get back with
this you will have to marry another man
which will hurt me so he would use his
fellip
not abusive and a woman if she wanted
the booster stuff she has to do it it
was me I want fuller she gets through
she has those rights by for a Jewish
woman in prison divorce is the most is
in their Asian writes a weekly sweet
that the throne of God straight spices
that's why it stays there this is not
because men used abused in people of
Arabia
yeah they used to miss around all I said
no here's the limit
and you can do nothing about and there
was even a time when a woman came and
she's completed the Prophet you know
what you complain about look at this she
said I'm not satisfied sexually because
you see this is intimacy is the right of
the woman in a man you have to do this
it's alright you can a woman can go and
say I'm not with my my husband is not
it's me with me she has the right to get
booze cuz that's her right that's right
yes so for example was free otherwise
she's pregnant she's pregnant but he
needs to pay her and look after her and
look kick her out from the house this is
what you have today you know I don't
know what that mean I hope it's not
anything really rudia
but but these fathers they call it sleep
around yeah and because these single
mothers who are on benefits and they've
just disappeared but it's a legal thing
in place that they can take a percentage
of their salary I'm good for that yeah
that's the reason why when you get
married sister you initiate a dowry so
you say $10,000
for 20 bucks you're right you know my
sister because that protects you
number one if he starts you know that is
there to use it's it's not you know you
have that as a security yeah you don't
translate these measures are in place to
protect the rights of women why does a
woman have a guardian it has to be
available because it's the projector
from harbouring there's a government out
there first ones that I love you romeo
giulia EST whatever bible you know how
many stories are here right above I was
reading a story one gear what I broke my
heart she was like before he was the one
I really love the paralyzed that ironic
speaking he's gone
the men from Mars and women from what
they've read Venus here so don't gone
right - the men say something
[Music]